now as I mentioned one of the great
tactics out there is blogs yeah they're
um you know date back to maybe boy 2003
does that make them grandfathers yet no
I don't think so blogs are incredibly
effective if the content is focused on
the kinds of issues that attract your
target audience if the content is all
about me me me me me here's the
promotion's that we had internally last
week and oh by the way here's here's our
organization's new products features and
benefits on but I can tell you from
firsthand experience this is a new blog
that we created for an organization
called the National transfer network
they are now attracting thousands of
people a month and it's not just
thousands the people it's thousands of
their target audience which would have
been hard to find otherwise these are
the people who are in college admissions
who are dealing with transfer students
how do you get those folks out of
woodwork you create compelling
information or content that they want to
read and then all of a sudden
interacting with them and so a heck of a
lot easier
[Music]
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here